Situation in Russland zu pregorians
mutmaßlichen Tod hat unsere
Korrespondentin Ina Rokal und nach
Moskau
hallo die Privatarmee der Wagner Söldner
ist im Netz sehr aktiv wie fallen da die
Reaktionen aus
wir wissen ehrlich gar nicht gar nicht
so genau was jetzt noch Reaktionen von
Wagner sind und was nicht es gibt ja
viele Kanäle die sich sehr nahezu Wagner
sehen die zum Teil auch von pregorien
gespielt worden die alle agieren jetzt
gerade
wer da wirklich noch für Wagner spricht
und was Wagner noch ist wissen wir gar
nicht aber es gibt natürlich
Beschuldigungen angeblich hätten eine
Verräter Russlands
pregorien umgebracht man ist sich da man
geht davon einem Anschlag aus andere
Kanäle im bei Telegramm die jetzt nicht
Wagner nahe stehen spekulieren in andere
Richtungen also das ist ein großes
Rätselraten was auch damit zu tun als
ist dass wir natürlich wenig von den
Behörden im Moment hören was wir gerade
noch gehört haben ist eine Information
aus Belarus die sagt dass tatsächlich
das Lager was die Wagner Leute in
Belarus hatten jetzt abgebaut wird er
ist offenbar ein Drittel der Zelte schon
verschwunden also ist was passiert
gestern ob es der sehr gut von
pregorians wirklich ist können wir
endgültig noch nicht sagen aber es tut
sich was bei diesem Wagner Leuten da
verändert sich gerade was
wir berichten denn die russischen
Staatsmedien über den Vorfall und was
hören oder lesen Sie auf anderen
Plattformen
die Staatsmedien erstaunlich
zurückhaltend das wichtigste die quasi
die Tagesschau des russischen Fernsehens
man kann die unsere uns nicht
vergleichen mit dem russischen Fernsehen
aber von der Reichweite her die
wichtigste Nachrichtensendung hat
gestern Abend überhaupt nicht berichtet
erst an an Stelle 17 kam eine kleine
Meldung heute kam es oder anstelle 14
das glaube ich heute heute gab es lange
nichts dann gab es wenige kleine
Berichte ähm eine der krawalltalkshows
hier nimmt sich das Themas an und sagte
das ist typisch Westen im Westen zeigen
alle mit dem Finger jetzt auf Putin als
sei er es gewesen aber ähm wirklich
ernsthaft berichtet wird kaum man
versucht das Ganze klein zu halten ist
mein Eindruck so wie man ja auch den
Namen pregorian in den letzten zwei
Monaten hier kaum noch erwähnt hat er
war einfach dann außer Gnade gefallen
und hatte seinen einen Fluss verloren
weil er galt ja lange als Freund von
Präsident Putin beide sind St Petersburg
und doch hat er sozusagen gemäutert hat
er sich einfach zu sicher gefühlt
die Spekulationen hört man jetzt oft
dass es möglicherweise sehr fahrlässig
war wenn es denn so stimmt wie wäre es
hören dass da alle Mann auf dieser
Passagierliste standen und alle in dem
Flugzeug waren also die wichtigsten
Köpfe von Wagner dass die tatsächlich da
gemeinsam in diesen Flieger gestiegen
sind dass das doch unvorsichtig ist
angesichts der Tatsache dass sie ich sag
mal vorsichtig umstritten sind in
Russland da setzt man sich nicht
gemeinsam in einen Flieger der hier im
Land herum fliegt
mag sein dass er sich zu sich hergefühlt
hat ist wirklich ganz schwer zu sagen
es wird in alle Richtungen spekuliert
übrigens gibt es hier auch die die
Variante die Spekulation dass er
vielleicht doch gar nicht an Bord war es
gab schon mal so ein Vorfall wo einen
hier gehen die pregorien an auf einem
Flieger war der dann abstürzte das war
2019 im Kongo und man hat ihn für tot
erklärt und später ist er dann doch
wieder aufgetaucht in einem Video wir
wissen ja von pregorian dass er wirklich
so ein behandlungskünstler und auch
versteckkünstler ist er hatte
verschiedene Identitäten man hat
verschiedene Pässe bei ihm gefunden und
wir wissen auch dass es Menschen gibt
die auf Wunsch oder
druck-gene pregosin einer von denen hat
jetzt gerade versucht sich
zurückzubenennen auf dem Amt weil er den
Namen nicht mehr tragen will also da
gibt es viele verwirr Spiele das kann
auch sein dass wir da sowas gerade
erlebt haben im Moment würde ich dazu
tendieren aufgrund der vielen Quellen im
Netz und der vielen Aussagen auch von
Menschen die ihn kennen und zu erreichen
versuchen das ist doch so wirkt als sei
prägen mit der Führungsriege von Wagner
gestern umgekommen aber es bleibt noch
ein großes Rätsel natürlich
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter wird er
weiter ermittelt oder ist das alles
abgeschlossen
es gibt eine er ist ein staatliches
ermittlungskomitee oder eine staatliche
Ermittlung im eine Ermittlungskommission
ist eingesetzt mit einem sehr erfahrenen
Mann an der Spitze der hier
Flugzeugabstürze untersucht da wird
sicherlich irgendwas von zu erwarten
sein ob wir wirklich alles erfahren
wissen wir nicht wichtig ist aber auch
wie es mit Wagner weitergehen wird denn
Russland braucht diese erfahrenen
Söldner das sind die harten Jungs die
dafür Russland den Job in Afrika
erledigen das kann man nicht ohne sie
machen das sind Kämpfer die viel Geld
kosten die hohe Gehälter haben bis zu 7
8000 € habe ich schon gehört dass die so
viel bekommen wenn sie wirklich an den
Kämpfen teilnehmen die wird man jetzt
irgendwie abwerben müssen ob die bereit
sind sich und das Kommando der
russischen Armee zu stellen ob die zu
einer der anderen Söldner Organisationen
gehen die ist ja gibt Gazprom zum
Beispiel unterhält so eine Truppe oder
ich glaube sogar zwei das werden wir
sehen aber das wird noch interessant zu
sehen sein was jetzt aus dieser doch
recht schlagkräftigen Truppe Wagner wird
so weil die ARD Russland Korrespondentin
Moskau vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung